Speaker 1: We're continuing our conversations with
a number of different candidates running in these
2022 midterm elections. And today, I'm going to be
speaking with Bobby Payton. Bobby is a Republican
running for election to the United States Senate
to represent Illinois and Bobby's work as a
portfolio manager. He's on the Republican
primary ballot in Illinois on June 28th.
The winner of that primary will face incumbent
Democratic Senator Tammy Duckworth in November.
Bobby, great to have you on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you so much for having me.
Speaker 1: You know, these conversations,
as many in my audience always tell me,
can be so illuminating because I,
as someone of the left, want to hear
the ideas of people that are Republicans and
that are on the right. And sometimes the ideas
make some sense and sometimes they don't. And we
talk about it and we sort of figure it out and
talk through things. So. Just to start, I've been
doing this almost like as a just gut check to,
to start figuring out where people are. So
forgive me if the answer to this question is easy.
Who's the current president of the United States?
Speaker 3: Who's the current president? Well,
I guess I guess it's a it's a
funny it's a funny question.
Speaker 1: Isn't it, really?
Speaker 3: Yeah. I do think we live in a very
interesting time where we have there's forces
beyond our visibility that like supernatural.
Speaker 1: Supernatural.
Speaker 3: Not supernatural. Oh there's, there's,
there's a group of extremely well wealthy beyond
wealthy like super wealthy individuals, not just
in the United States but globally that call the
shots on both parties, not just one party. Okay.
And and so it's almost as though there's a bunch
of horse trading taking place behind the scenes.
And so, you know, from that perspective, I
do believe the will of the American people
was ignored in 2020. And the person that's in
there is is the person that these globalists
put in. And that's that's that's in you know,
what I would tell you is. I have overwhelming
proof. I'll actually be releasing proof from about
Illinois tomorrow. General Flynn will be in town.
I have a fundraiser for my campaign. And Vander
Steel. Doug Billings, Jovan Pulitzer. Liz Harris
from Arizona. Edward Solomon, whose done work,
mathematical work on proving that our elections
across the aisle, folks, the unit party is very
real. And frankly, it's undermining you and me.
Speaker 1: Okay, but so, Bobby, that's that's a
lot. So let's take it piece by piece. Sure. Who
are the rich globalists that you're talking about?
Speaker 3: Well, there's there's there's a there's
a there's a corporate class. Okay.
A global corporate class that exist
that considers themselves to have more rights
than any individuals within any nation state. Who
are the CEOs of major global corporations?
Speaker 1: But can you name some specific people?
Speaker 3: So like, for example,
you know, think of BlackRock.
BlackRock controls $9 trillion of assets through
their their their structure. He's he's been in
control for over 30 years. Okay. Who has one? Bill
Gates is one who parlayed his fortune in Microsoft
into other areas. Okay. You know, so you can you
can argue that Elon Musk is one who's who's kind
of like leaning from left, back to right and
possibly right for the first time in his life.
Okay. That's another one. You know, Michael
Eisner of Disney used to be one before he retired.
Then there never is always this legacy wealth
that we all know exists, like the Rockefellers,
you know, the DuPonts, for example, the DuPont
family backed the individual running for U.S.
Senate in Pennsylvania. There's like 4000 DuPonts.
Okay. You know, and so it's it's it's it's not
it's not like one boogeyman this guy got.
Speaker 1: It's a bunch of people. Okay.
And so do you trust the results from Pennsylvania
from earlier this week, where this right wing guy
who believes the election was stolen in 2020,
Doug Mastriano, he won on Tuesday. Do you trust
those results or do you question them?
Speaker 3: I think that that the results
are our what's the word I would use is they're
they're probably manufactured to some degree.
Yes. So I think it's it's across party lines.
Speaker 1: So Doug didn't really win.
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, here's my
question is, if if we were playing a board game,
you and I and two other people and and,
you know, somehow we knew that there was
some some some stuff flawed with the way the
game was set up. Okay. And we were playing.
And, you know, one of us ended up winning.
Right. But we knew that it was flawed massively.
Would it really feel like a win?
Speaker 1: Okay. But I'm asking
a different question, and I love this because
we're really getting down to brass tacks here.
In in 20 in the November 2020 election. Joe Biden
was awarded the state of Pennsylvania. Do you
believe Joe Biden won in 2020 in Pennsylvania?
Speaker 3: Absolutely not. Okay. And
I and let me explain how.
Speaker 1: But but I'll let
you explain it. But I want to just make
sure we go sequentially. Two days ago,
Doug Mastriano won in Pennsylvania's gubernatorial
primary. Do you believe he actually won?
Speaker 3: I think that I know I have not
looked at the data to make that assessment. Oh,
so I looked at the data with regards to 2020.
I actually broke out all 67 counties of the
state of Pennsylvania, and I showed how they had
destroyed entire last names of voters from both
Republican and the Democratic side to create
the outcome that they wanted mathematically.
And it showed up in the voter registration
files. In the final result, they literally
destroyed 695,000 individuals, names that
didn't vote the way their algorithm wanted.
And it's a brilliant way to hide their crime.
Speaker 1: Why didn't a single court accept this?
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, a couple of
things. Number one, that that information
was provided to the Georgia state Senate.
Speaker 1: Wait, wait, hold on. You're
talking about Pennsylvania, but
now you're talking about Georgia.
Speaker 3: Because I release those results. I
testified before the Georgia state Senate with.
Speaker 1: The Pennsylvania.
Speaker 3: Results because
those votes were shifted to Georgia.
Speaker 1: They shifted votes from Pennsylvania
to Georgia.
Speaker 3: Georgia,
like a stock portfolio algorithm.
Speaker 1: And who did it? People in
Pennsylvania or people in Georgia.
Speaker 3: Somebody whoever has
the power to control the voter
registration files in the voting
system of those two states, then.
Speaker 1: What person would have
control over both systems in two different.
Speaker 3: States? I think that there's multiple
entities that probably have that the means to do
that. Like who let just say the DNC and the RNC.
Maybe they did it together. For all I know, the.
Speaker 1: DNC and the RNC took control of the
Pennsylvania and Georgia systems to shift votes
from one to the other, but Biden won both. So
what was the point in shifting them?
Speaker 3: Because because once again,
I think they do some horse trading
behind the scenes, both parties.
And they and they collude to create the outcome
that they agree upon based on these mega-donors.
Speaker 1: All right. So to go back to the
question, who's currently the president,
do you have an answer you can give?
Speaker 3: I think that I think that right now
in in the international arena of the
world, President Biden is recognized
as the president of the United States.
Speaker 1: Do you believe that someone
else like maybe Trump is actually the president?
Speaker 3: I have no information to make that
kind of judgment or assessment. Okay. You know,
so, no, I'm not living in a delusional world,
you know, where somebody is thinking, you
know, there's some kind of like secret.
Speaker 1: Shadow presidency
or something like, oh, no.
Speaker 3: No, no, I'm good. I don't believe in
any of that. Oh, but I do agree with Elon Musk
said, which he he said whoever controls Biden's
teleprompter is really running this country.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 3: So with that statement.
Speaker 1: There are so many fascinating things
in a Q&A you did with a paper not long ago, let me
actually mention exactly what paper it is. It was
with the local newspaper, Sha Local, the SHA Local
News Network. You did a Q&A. It's fascinating.
Before we get on to the substance, Bobby,
in looking at your answers, you do something that
Trump does, which is you randomly capitalize words
in the middle of sentences that aren't
proper nouns. So like in your answers,
you randomly capitalize the word farming
and the word chemicals. And I could give
you a dozen other examples. Can you help me
understand what's with the random capitalization?
Speaker 3: Yeah. My wife. My wife.
It's a big pet peeve of hers.
So it's a wonderful question. And sometimes and
it's very hard because when you write something,
you don't always necessarily have people keen
on certain words. So I do know that it's not
grammatically correct. Okay. I've had this
discussion with my wife plenty of times and I say
I capitalize it because I want to catch people's
attention instead of seizing the word or bolding
it. I do something that causes them to pause. And
so I hope it was effective with you. You know, she
thinks it's ineffective to communicate this way.
Speaker 1: I agree with your wife. I agree
with your wife. It made know it was such a
distraction because I was like, does Bobby
think these are proper nouns or what's.
Speaker 3: Going on now? Okay. Okay. So
it's a personality quirk. Fairness. You know,
to your point. My wife has brought it up.
Others have brought it up. Maybe I. Maybe
it's time for me to stop doing that.
Speaker 1: Something to think about. Okay, good.
So now let me ask you another question in this
same Q&A with the news local newspaper, when you
were asked about January 6th. One of the things
you said is you really want Antifa and Black
Lives Matter investigated for what happened on
January 6th. Do you have any evidence that
Antifa and Black Lives Matter are the ones
that committed crimes at the Capitol on that day?
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, I'm not sure if I
linked it right with that question. I might have
mentioned it in the same question, but I'd have
to double check. I don't have those notes in front
of me. But in terms of those two groups, Antifa,
First Amendment, which is anti Antifa, right.
It's a play on words. It's pretty brilliant.
Speaker 1: No, it actually means
anti. It means anti-fascist.
Speaker 3: Well, it means Antifa. First Amendment.
Speaker 1: Well, no, you'd have the people.
The people who it's sort of like if you told
me my name means something different. Like if
I'm coming up with the name, I'm coming up with
it because I know what it means to me. Right?
Antifa says it's anti-fascist. We have to go
by what they are meaning with it, don't we?
Speaker 3: Well, I mean, that's it's you know,
it's kind of funny for you to say that, because on
the left right now, there's people that identify
as being a woman that are biologically a male.
And, you know, and they they can tell you that
they have to have a certain pride. So I understand
we're going to agree to disagree on what it means.
Speaker 1: Well, right. Let's get the focus. So
you were asked about the riots. And what you said
about that was that it was a peaceful gathering,
manipulated by the political establishment. And
you want Antifa and BLM investigated for it?
Speaker 3: Yes, I do. You think I do not have
evidence, you know, who were involved. But I you
know, but I think that I do believe that people
from both sides of the aisle, the unit party,
corrupt Democrats, corrupt Republicans, were both
involved in staging this incident. And in a way
that if you notice what happened after that event,
yeah, we never did get to see any disputes with,
you know, like the, you know, the the floor of
Congress debate, the merits of issues that arose
in the ballots properly. And all these different
states, they they kind of brushed through
that much faster as a result of that event.
Speaker 1: Well, yes, because they realized
that it was going to serve no productive
purpose, that at the end of the day,
there wasn't really any substantive evidence or
fraud nor a legal mechanism to deny Joe Biden the
presidency. And they said it's the middle of the
night. We all want to go home. Let's do what is
obviously going to be the correct thing to do.
Speaker 3: You know what I would love to do,
David? Yeah, I'm going to,
if you don't mind. Yeah. Make
sure you send me your email address, please.
Speaker 1: Tomorrow you'll send me the evidence.
Speaker 3: Okay. I will send you a deck. Yeah.
With regards to my presentation, find some.
With the slides from tomorrow. Fine. And I'll.
And I'm more than happy if you have a Dropbox.
Okay. I'm glad to send you some data for you
to retrieve from the voter registration files
of the five battleground states. The work that
I did, as well as my write ups and I'll gladly
let you read it, debate it. It's all it's I'm.
Speaker 1: Glad to do it. I'm glad to do it. But
Bobby, in terms of my question on Antifa and BLM,
you believe people from both sides were involved.
But I believe that before you you said that
you said you have no evidence Antifa or BLM
were involved. That's what you said, right?
Speaker 3: I do not have evidence they were
involved. I do think that they are based on
other things that I've seen. But I don't have the
smoking gun, so to speak. I'm not an investigator
asking that there is an investigation held.
Speaker 1: And there have been so many
which have found either that Joe Biden
won by even more or like it doesn't sound
like you're necessarily satisfied with
investigations when they don't go your way.
What type of investigation would you accept?
Speaker 3: Well, well, couple of things. Yeah.
So, number one, when you when you look at it,
let's let's talk about the state of Arizona. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So Arizona. There's Maricopa was where
the audit took place. Right. Everybody knows.
Speaker 1: That. And you were involved
with the cyber ninja stuff, right?
Speaker 3: I was involved with. No,
no, I was not employed during that
audit. Okay. Work on the honor and the
voter registration files. Okay. And
proved out that there was a set of voters
inserted into the voter registration files
that can be called upon when needed to sway the
the results in any particular precinct.
Speaker 1: And they had they all were
registered to the same address. Is that correct?
Speaker 3: No, no, they weren't. That's not the
case, that they were all registered to
the same address. Oh. What happens is
in. In the case. So let's let's talk about why you
need very little to to rig an election, especially
when you look at the results. Okay. If if there
was, there's an average of about 1000 people
per precinct in this country. So if the vote came
out to be 501 to 499, you're talking about what?
You're talking about a two vote differential,
right? Five. A one minus four. 99. Yes. So now if
you wanted to sway that result the other way from
five a 1 to 4 or nine, you only need three votes.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 3: You need to go from five 1 to 502. So
three divided by a thousand is 30 basis points.
It's 3/10 of 1%. So a thousand goes into 11,000
times. So per million people that voted three
times a thousand is 3000 votes. So in the case of
Arizona, 3.6 million approximately people voted.
So three times 3.6 is 10.8 thousand. You only
need to steal 10,800 votes to affect the election.
If it was 501 to 499 and you put it to 50251502.
Speaker 1: But this is an imaginary
scenario where you're saying.
Speaker 3: I'm in.
Speaker 1:
Every precinct. Okay. All right. Go ahead.
Speaker 3: No, but here here's what I would say.
The data is when when you mapped out the
data across the 700, I think it was 742
precincts within Maricopa. I think I believe
there are 742 precincts. And you calculated
what was the number that would be needed in
advance. So to rig the election and you could
generate it before a single ballot was cast
and the numbers came out the way they came out
on Election Day, you would call in the question
mathematically, how can somebody come up with
the algorithm for how to do this
before a single ballot was cast?
Speaker 1: What evidence do
you have that anybody did that,
though? You're just looking at the numbers.
Speaker 3: I think that I'm more than happy
to send it to you. Okay. I'll
send you Edward Solomon's.
Speaker 1: It's coming out tomorrow, right?
Speaker 3: Well. Well, I was explaining Arizona
tomorrow. I'm going to explain Illinois.
Oh, okay. And Illinois. I've never exposed
Illinois. I'm going to expose the Senate race for
Durbin back in 2000 and the Senate race, the U.S.
Senate race for Duckworth, my opponent, if I make
it through the primary right. In 2016. And I will
show you the data. I will do a video. Actually,
I'm not sure if we're going to live stream it,
but I will gladly send you my supporting document,
please my video, and I will and I'll explain
how they're modifying the voter registration
files and using optimizers as well as random
functions that exist in Microsoft Excel. You do
this, anybody will be able to replicate what I'm
talking about if they have Microsoft Excel. Okay.
Speaker 1: Bobby, I've got to ask you, because we
are out of time, what would what evidence, if
it could be presented, would convince you that
Joe Biden just won in 2020? Is there such
evidence? If anybody could show it to you,
that would make you say, you know what? Biden won.
Speaker 3: I think the evidence that would
convince me that that Biden won is is if
you said, Bobby in your state of Illinois.
Yeah. There's 8.9 million people registered to
vote. And of those 8.9 million people, this is
how many that, you know, were between, you know,
the legal age to vote, you know, 18 plus. And
they they they exist in our society in the form
of, you know, there was 6 million tax returns
filed or there was 150, you know, like 500,000
Social Security checks paid into the state or,
you know, 200,000, you know, culvert checks that
were cashed. And if if I. Can see the receipts
of the economic activity of the of the state of
who's doing these votes. And it ties out to our
federal tax receipts are our federal spend.
You know, because I'm not saying, you know,
I don't if somebody is retired and they don't have
a tax return and they still get government money,
they still have a right to vote. So I'm all for
like, oh, this is how many receive the check that
voted. This is how many pay taxes they have voted.
And then if if all of a sudden there's no record
that they exist economically speaking, you know,
you know, like that would that would put this to
rest for me real quick. I'd be like, okay.
Speaker 1: It seems we have all of
that. That's strange. Listen, Bobby.
Speaker 3: We don't have it. We don't have
it cross-reference with the actual votes that
take place in our system at the current time.
Speaker 1: Is your assertion that Joe Biden
didn't even really win Illinois? Is that what
you're claiming?
Speaker 3:
I don't know if he won Illinois.
Speaker 1: You don't know.
Speaker 3: I know that he win. He I could tell
you right now that in Illinois, based on my
my research, there's well over 1.6 million
fraudulent registrations in the state of
Illinois at the present time.
Speaker 1: Okay. But so
you're saying that even Illinois, which was
won by Democrats in 2016, 2012, 2008, 24,
2000, etc.. 1996. I mean, you're saying that those
were all fraudulent or just in 2020, the Democrat.
Speaker 3: That we need to look at all the
elections going back at least 20 years since
the machines entered the scene.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. So so you
think maybe even like Bill Clinton's
win in Illinois in 92 was fraudulent?
Speaker 3: I didn't say that. We
didn't have machines back then.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. 96, 1996.
Speaker 3: The machines came in after
this criminal by the name of George Bush, as
I believe he stole the election from Al Gore
in Florida with the hanging chad inch incident.
Speaker 1: But in 2000 and 2004,
where the Dems were, Al Gore and Kerry
won Illinois, even though Bush had the
machines. You think those might have been.
Speaker 3: Part of the machines? Came in after
the 2000 election. Okay.
Speaker 1: So 2004.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So I'm saying
is what I'm saying is that, that
that event where George Bush stole the election
with the hanging chad incident with his brother,
who was governor at the time. Yeah. Jeb Bush that
ushered in these machines. And I think ever since
these machines have come online, I think it makes
it easy to possibly manipulate and steal elections
across the whole the whole ticket. And the math
will show it. I'm going to I'm very happy. I will
send you please. All of my stuff. Please. And it's
all going to be presented tomorrow. I have over,
I think, about 300 plus people coming tomorrow.
I invited the press to be there. Good. And I and
I will I will open it up for peer review
and people that love math and statistics,
they can look at it themselves and see what I'm
talking about. Love it. If you want to talk about
it after you go through it and pick it apart.
Speaker 1: Allow me to do that. Yeah, I will take
a look at it and then we will go from there. And
you know, Bobbie, I have a feeling you're going
to take these beliefs to your grave. I don't think
you'll ever be disabused of any of these thoughts.
I don't I don't think the evidence really matters.
Speaker 3: I think I think that, you know,
I think I think that what will play out will play
out. But, yes, I do. Can I just say this? Yeah.
When this plays out the way it's going to be meant
to play out. Yep. My biggest hope about this whole
thing. Yes. Is that when you have a difference or
I have a difference and who we back that goes in,
you know, to to run for office, that your vote is
not diluted one iota and my vote is not diluted.
Beautiful. Right now, I don't think either one
of us. I do not have any confidence that my vote
is not being undermined in some way or your vote
might not be undermined in some way. And so I will
continue to work to get that solved because
at the end of the day, we're all Americans.
Speaker 1: First we are. And on the.
Speaker 3: Left, look, my my godfather, my son
is a huge Democrat. He I think he actually
you know, he calls Pelosi his girl when he
was living out there. He's an airline pilot
and he's the godfather. And, you know, yeah,
I love the guy. I've known him over 20 years.
We disagree, but we both want it to be fair,
you know, and I think I think at first he
was skeptical. I've sent him information
over the past year. He sees it. He's more open
minded to seeing if it truly is taking place.
But the reality is, is in my state of
Illinois, they're both in on it, folks.
Both the Republicans and the Democrats are doing
this to us. And I don't think it was just in 2020.
I think it goes back at least two decades.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, we're going to look at
all of it. We've been speaking with Bobby Payton,
who is running for U.S. Senate in Illinois.
He is in a primary which is at the end of
June. If he wins, he will face incumbent
Democratic Senator Tammy Duckworth. Bobby,
illuminating. I can't quite literally,
you're lit up. Your face is completely lit up.
I swear I'm going to go with that. I don't know.
But it's been it's been an illuminating
conversation, metaphorically and literally.
Speaker 3: And can I can I mention
to your viewers that check me out
at Bobby Payton dot com here on Telegram.
Speaker 1: Yes. And please get us the data on
Illinois and we will look at it very strongly.
Speaker 3: Awesome. I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, David.